it has been a while since i've been able
to say this
but sometimes i really love being wrong
low-key episode six season finale
because yes we have confirmed season two
is happening so spoilers pretty much
right off the bat i should tell you that
if you haven't watched the episode yet
i liked it a lot
and um that's all i'm going to say we're
doing spoilers cause
the episode dives into spoilers pretty
immediately
now if you go back to my earlier uh
reviews in this
i've said a number of times that it
seems
super obvious that they are setting up
kang the conqueror to be the big bad of
this
and for that reason well not only for
that reason but for that reason amongst
a few others
i was really hoping that would not be
the case the other reasons why i didn't
want that to be the case
include the fact that i don't think kang
is a very interesting character
and i was very much afraid of a repeat
of
the whole uh agatha harkness thing where
they just reveal someone and have it be
like
done and like but we have no context for
who this is who cares
because like i'm sorry all respect to
catherine hunt the act of the heart does
thing did
not work in wanda vision at all and yet
when they revealed kang and i knew it
was him
because the door is open and there's
jonathan majors and i watched lovecraft
country so i recognized him and i
already knew he'd been cast as kang for
the upcoming third ant-man movie so
immediately i went uh crap and then he
started talking
i was like okay
all right this um
iteration of kang i love
now some of this is the writing but some
of it or a lot of it honestly is what
john of the mages is bringing to the
part
this much more casual
sense this sort of like yeah no i know
what's going on what you gonna do about
like it's devoid of all of the i am the
conqueror you will bow before me i am
all powerful
nonsense that you associate with the
character like kang
kang does not give up primitive
like that that's so boring he is not
he's not boring like and here's another
thing i don't get to talk about very
often
exposition scenes especially long ones
that have to explain a crap ton of
things
where not a lot of action or stuff
actively moving the plot forward really
happens
they tend to get derided a lot and
that's fair they usually suck and grind
the story to a halt and provide
information that probably
could have been done more organically
without stopping the actual inertia of
the story
but you know i'm actually a real big
sucker
for a good exposition scene it wasn't
uncommon
for me in my younger years like to
really just
soak in and want to to deliver you know
the actor me wanting to deliver the
lines for
good exposition explanations i used to
watch scenes
in movies where you know the scientist
character that somebody would
explain how it works like and i'd just
be like oh
they're good in the rapid fire they make
it they make what should be boring fun
and this makes what on paper should be
boring
fun and this is a really interesting
thing for me to break down because
so many reasons this should not work and
look
if it didn't work for you i'm not going
to say you're wrong
but for me and what bugs me
and the kinds of things that drive me
nuts this should have fallen down
so hard and it doesn't
how does this work when normally a
nearly episode long
long exposition should not work
especially as a finale and where
the reveal of a character in command of
everything who is someone we have never
seen before
within the context of this show and who
has no meaning if you don't know the
outside material
that should not work but it does
why couple of things
first is one of the big fall downs for
the egg of the harkness reveal yes i'm
gonna keep harping on that suck it up
was the fact that we weren't
really in need of a mastermind
what we were needing in one division was
an explanation for
wanda herself why is she doing this
why doesn't she appreciate the damage
that she's doing by doing this
how is that going to resolve none of
that and that was like
especially at that point what the show
was hinging itself on
and none of that requires a villain and
in fact i found a villain to be
detrimental
to that so when she reveals herself it's
like
not only was i going who the heck are
you i was going
why are you even here we don't need you
but here we have been building very
steadily
towards figuring out who is manipulating
this
so it's not like oh and i'm behind it
all when
there is no need for somebody to be
behind at all here they've been
deliberately on that path so inserting
the
big person who's controlling everything
is actually a
payoff to what has come before where it
flatly was not
in one division it just happened and
didn't gel
here it does because they built towards
it so that's the first thing
the other thing is well the other two
things
is that one the information we get
from him uh is not is not just
reiterating stuff that we could have
already figured out it's
explaining the specific rules of how we
got here and what's been going on
things that i did not assume correctly
up to this point
and on top of that between
how he interacts with loki and sylvie
how they react to him even though it's
mostly conversation
does still move the plot forward and
still reveal
these characters now that's not to say
that sylvia or loki was
under characterized or we didn't know
what they were about up to this point
now suddenly we do no of course we
we're getting a very good sense of them
but a really good way
to solidify characters
is to put them under pressure when the
chips are truly down
what do they do are they in agreement
are they in conflict and watching that
play out
was really rewarding so
it just this is the kind of thing
like again on paper what this episode is
doing is the kind of thing that i would
say
nearly any show don't do that
but not because it's impossible to do
right but it's because you have to nail
every element of it and if you don't
then it won't work and this again for me
at least
nailed every part it needed to nail
the character delivering the exposition
is fun
to listen to the explanations he's
giving
are consistent with what we already know
yet are also providing us new
information
the way that characters interact with
this information is
not designed in a way to simply keep the
conversation going but instead reveals
things
about them and their priorities the fact
that you know to highlight a single
moment
loki going so this was all a
manipulation and
kang who doesn't actually even get named
in this but i'm just going to call him
that anyway because that's who he is
he looks in and goes it's really
interesting that that's your first
assumption
exactly exactly because
the word the way that this could have
played out that would have been painful
would have been
kang starts to explain what's going on
hits a stopping point and then
basically to remind us and that there
are other people in the scene and have
it not be completely monologued
you have sophie or loki basically prompt
him for the next piece of information
and it just keeps the conversation going
in a
completely functional robotic sense and
this doesn't do
that it keeps the conversation going yes
but by having
loki and sylvie give responses and
reactions that
make sense and again build towards
how they are going to differ in their
reaction
when it really comes down to it at the
end
this is really good
this made me so like the more i think
about it the more i like okay so
i also said i like a lot of the ideas
that we get and a lot of
the clarifications about how this has
been working up to this point already
and that's
that's the other thing it could have
been the other thing that really could
have pulled this apart is if
it's like oh here's what's actually
going on and like it doesn't gel with
what we knew before
or it just like why is that better or
have to be different from what we
thought was going on and i i even had
that thought
at a couple of points where i was like
okay
i get all this but why the fake
timekeepers why couldn't
you just be hey i'm in charge around
here
and we don't directly get an answer to
that but we get enough things in here
that
allows me to headcanon something that i
like which is that
this is just how this guy operates and
he's the only one
left in charge this is what he's gonna
do and or
having seen as much of the possibilities
as he's seen he's determined that
for whatever reason and it's probably
not worth delving into
things are going to flow better if he
has figureheads
so either one of those works and there's
enough stuff
put in here that i can slot that in and
make sense and answers a question that
otherwise was going to bug the heck out
of me
but i love the idea that
this multiversal war which was a concept
introduced in the very first episode of
this show
isn't actually about
the different universes being unable to
coexist
it's about this one freaking guy
so it's not a dead set determination
that all these different universes
can't work together
or be in harmony it's that this
one guy this one jerk
has versions of himself who won't get
along
and will insist on trying to conquer or
overcome
or be in charge or eliminate the rest
i kind of love that i kind of love that
the entire reason
that a multiverse is a danger is because
of the
infinite number of variants of this one
guy that should annoy me because
normally i don't
like characters as singular entities
being
that important but the thing is he's not
really
important in the grand scale in terms of
like
the universe revolves around him it's
just he's always a
problem however you slice it even if a
particular incarnation of him isn't a
problem
as soon as he starts encountering other
incarnations he's going to become a
problem
i really like that it's it's just
mind-bending enough that i'm like oh
oh and also it gives us the catharsis
of getting to see sylvie kill him
and him saying i'll see you soon or
whatever his exact line was
basically saying look you thought this
version of me was bad
you've just unleashed a whole bunch of
worse
versions of me
that is because
when we saw him i'm like well we're not
going to be able to get resolution on
this because we know he's showing up
again later in ant-man 3 but it's not
going to be this version of him
it's going to be a different version of
him which is going to first of all free
things up continuity wise
second of all doesn't rob us of some
degree of closure
some degree of catharsis in dealing with
him here
and yet also knowing oh this may have
set off something way
worse i
i don't care about kang i've never cared
about kang i think kang's
boring i love this
i i love how this works i love how he
talks i love his interactions i love the
giddiness
when they pass the threshold and he's
like i don't actually know what's going
to happen from here on out
i love his admitting to a certain degree
of deception up to that point so
that if you have the need to poke holes
in what he said in order to have it make
more sense in your head you can do that
because we already know he lied about
certain things
maybe he was lying about other things
maybe we those will or won't get filled
in later but
i like being given an explanation that
for me fits but also has the wiggle room
that if you need to adjust certain parts
of this so it
makes sense in your head you can do that
because he's already been shown to be
a liar at least in part
i really like this and i like this guy
i never thought i'd say that about kang
that's
bonkers to me now i've spent pretty much
the whole time talking about him
and not talking about our other
characters so
sylvie and loki
watching the two of them start to
diverge
in how they think they should be dealt
with was really well done
because that could have felt very
manufactured that could have felt very
forced by circumstance that the story
basically needs them to disagree so
they just will because well that's
that's what we need to have happen to do
the ending we want to do
but it feels properly motivated by
character and again loki has a line
that makes that clear you can't trust
anyone
and i can't be trusted this is why we
are coming to different conclusions
this is why we can't agree on the best
way to deal with this
and you could argue that
that's dumbing it down and saying it
plainly to an audience that should have
been trusted to get it and like
i'm not going to say that you're wrong
but i kind of appreciated
that being said because it shows to me
that the
writers and the actors understand
this because one of the risks you run
sometimes when you don't lay this stuff
out plainly is i'm left here going
did you actually know what you were
doing or did you stumble into doing the
right thing by accident
and that made it clear like no they knew
what they were doing and i like i i like
that as a reassurance sometimes
and also like can i talk about
how stupidly smoothly this is going to
leap into ant-man 3
and the multiverse of madness and stuff
like that because
one of the things i had assumed going
into these disney plus
shows was that they they can only matter
so much
because marvel has been very smart
about not actually making
understanding their franchises as
interdependent
as it seems you feel like you have to
see
all of them to keep up with what's going
on and
really if you're watching the avengers
films the team up movies
you do to the extent of that way you'll
know who everybody is but as far as
following the individual franchises now
you don't really need to there's only a
couple times that
knowledge in one franchise was super
dependent on
information about what happened in
earlier ones like thor ragnarok has a
certain amount of dependence that you
saw the avengers
that's there but the first two thor
movies other than a couple of scant
references
pretty self-contained you don't really
and what little information you need to
know about what happened in between them
gets delivered all three iron man movies
same thing
all three captain america movies
honestly are shockingly self-contained
and really the only thing you're left
going is like okay there's definitely
some new people in play but
you figure out who they are in this
situation so you can still move forward
the entire mcu is far less
interdependent
than you think it is and my assumption
going into these shows
was that well they i was seeing fans
build up like
these are going to tie in so much more
to
the movies than say agents of shield or
definitely the netflix stuff did
and while i kind of thought well they'll
tie more but they won't tie in that much
because they can't well
they managed to tie them in more without
breaking that rule of
well you won't understand the movies
unless you see the tv because
honestly that would have been a very
stupid thing for marvel to do
is to make understanding the tv shows
dependent on the movies
other way around uh to make
understanding the movies depending on
the tv shows because
look raw numbers fewer people are gonna
watch all these shows
than go to the movies that's like that's
just what happens
so you can't make understanding the
movie dependent on the show
and yet they're finding a way where the
films
are going to leap directly off
of things done in the shows but it's
still gonna work self-contained i
pointed this out already
with um with falcon in the winter
soldier
so that whole show was about sam
becoming sure enough in himself that he
felt like he actually deserved to carry
the shield
but if you skip that and you just watch
the move if you go from an end game
where he's given the shield to captain
america four
where we will see sam being captain
america
you'll just make the leap that somewhere
in between he got comfortable with it
he's good in this role
and you you don't have to actually watch
the series where that happened
it's a safe assumption to make and with
this
this does set up in a very direct way
the multiverse of madness doctor strange
movie that we're going to be getting
and also possibly um spider-man
um no way home we'll know a little bit
more about that later but also
potentially that as well
while at the same time
not nest being necessary to follow those
because going into those movies all they
have to do is say oh
goodness there's a multiverse but only
in
loki did they establish the rule of well
there can't be a multiverse there can
only truly be one timeline at any given
time
it got hinted at in end game but like
here
it with the tv and everything there must
be only one timeline
and then by the end they break it so if
you skipped loki
you're just existing in a world where
okay there's multi branches and there's
a multiverse
now if you watched loki you set up and
watched that all play out
but going into these other films that
are going to have multiversal aspects
like that's that'll just be the way it
is going in
the balance of interconnecting these
things
and yet not making it 100 dependent like
again
you'll understand better if you follow
everything but like you truly do not
have to you can like ask a friend hey
what happened to this oh well
there's a multiverse now okay cool
that's like and i'm pretty sure the
movies that are going to be dependent on
the multiverse are going to establish
that in their own way anyways
i keep waiting
for this whole thing to collapse in on
itself
as they build it up and keep moving
forward it gets more complicated
and it just isn't happening
like it still might eventually but
holy cow god what the heck else do i
have to say um
mobius's confrontation with ravona liked
that so she's still around i'll be
curious to see where they go with her
we've gotten out this situation where
the tva is definitely still around but
they seem to have a different remit
and now we've got it looks like a
version of kang who is more directly in
control
and isn't using the time keeper lie so
it's like oh crap
uh are we now immediately dealing with
the worst version of of the guy we just
met
possibly is the tva's whole remit and
how they operate is it the same
is it different it seems to be slightly
altered and we're now looking at a
situation where
the timeline within the tva itself
appears to have been changed because
mobius doesn't recognize loki
because up to this point i think the
assumption or at least my assumption
was that the tva is kind of immune to
branching timelines it's like in its own
bubble
you know these variants and these
timelines these things happen we get rid
of it and the main timeline continues
but no matter what we do like within our
little bubble
we're not affected by any of this but
now they have been
which first of all is a solid indicator
of how much things just got shaken up
but also that's a decent hook
going into the second season i do think
it's a little bit risky
having mobius not recognize loki because
i would hate to see them have to sink a
bunch of time into re-establishing that
relationship when it was already built
up really well
we'll see what happens with that with
the next season happening next year but
again we get some closure we get some
catharsis
we get a sense of the end of a chapter
at least
with this season while still setting up
what could come next not only here but
in ant-man
in the multiverse of madness again
possibly the next spider-man
this does so much
and is juggling so much it has to thread
so many
so many needles how'd it pull it off
i don't know but
uh i've been saying up to this point
that i've been liking this show
but i was gonna be nervous until after
the finale because so much was gonna
hinge on this
at this point with this finale
i can safely say i love it
i love loki the series
and it is my favorite of the disney
plush shows so far
it's going to be tough to top it's also
going to be tough to pick up on a second
season
and do it as well as this so i'll be
nervous again but for right now
i love this this is gold
what did you think of the low-key season
finale
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it like share subscribe
why am i counting down this way i don't
know i'm just rolling with it
ah i have a patreon that is my living
if you want to help me do this and also
get rewards for doing so you can check
that out plus there's youtube
memberships with
which have their own rewards uh but you
don't have to do
any of that because at the end of the
day
you're the council i just run the
meetings you've got free will
i don't know everything that's going to
happen and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
bye
[Music]